[Musique]
que peut-on faire avec deux billets de
500 francs en 1984 ils sont très à
tenter leur chance à hésiter entre le
nécessaire et le superflu
c'est à vous de décider qui les gagnera
retenez le bon numéro
vous gagnez mille francs et vous avez
une heure pour les dépenses et vous
faites quoi
les folies des folies je crois que je
partirai de nation et robert première
classe des premières classes gérer
champs-elysées fast food ou fast food de
luxe un bon hamburger jeux repas en
première classe je rentre chez moi je me
couche les folies et folie vous avez une
argent
alors si je gagne me francs je crois que
la première chose que je ferai c'est de
d'aller dans un hôtel de luxe
mais pas n'importe lequel parce qu'il ya
deux hôtels que j'aime particulièrement
dans paris c'est l'intercontinental et
le plaza athénée
simplement j'ai peur qu'une chambre pour
une nuit coûte plus que mille francs et
j'aime particulièrement le luxe pourquoi
parce que justement le luxe à quelque
chose de superflu bon j'ai beaucoup de
besoins donc je veux dire mille francs
c'est beaucoup et en même temps pas
assez mais je pense qu'actuellement
bon je passe rennaise où un journal pour
trouver un emploi
puis ces dépenses restent toute façon je
les garde pas les dépenses c'est sûr et
j'ai deux personnages qui m'intéresse
deux hommes célèbres simplement parce
qu'ils sont sympathiques et que je les
trouve intéressant c'est pas à cause de
leur nom là c'est bernard pivot et
l'autre site yves montand je suis désolé
pour leurs épouses pas pouvoir les
conviés mais si on divise mais il part
si ça fait pas beaucoup par tête de pipe
du moins dans ce genre de restaurant et
je ne veux pas vous raconter
si je gagne mes frères aujourd'hui ben
aujourd'hui ça tomberait bien parce que
justement c'est mon anniversaire
alors ce serait un beau cadeau mais
qu'est ce que vous en feriez qu'est-ce
que j'en ferais c'est à dire que miss
france ce serait pas assez pour
satisfaire mon rêve mon rêve actuel ce
serait de partir en croisière
alors peut-être qu'avec 1000 francs jeu
j'achèterais un billet de loterie ou
plusieurs billets de loterie j'aurais au
loto pour gagner le gros lot est alors
partir vraiment croisière et faire
réaliser mes souhaits quoi bien je vais
tout de suite le mettre sur mon compte
en banque
du fait que je suis pas mal à découvert
et je crois que c'est la meilleure façon
dont je puisse utiliser cet argent pour
l'instant c'est nécessaire ah c'est tout
à fait nécessaire mais petite bouffe une
petite nénette quoi pour changer les
idées enfin oui pour changer d idée
c'est important c'est important ça c'est
important
suivant ce que l'on est quoi enfin
suivant l'individu et pour vous pour moi
c'est important à peu est-ce que c'est
nécessaire ou superflus ça serait
d'ailleurs pour moi ce serait nécessaire
peut-être oui ça enfin oui on peut dire
nécessaire
c'est un peu dur à dire mais enfin c'est
pas fou c'est le charme de la vie c'est
acheter n'importe quoi pour faire
plaisir
un petit foulard en soie ou quelque
chose comme ça et vous aimez ça ah oui
j'aime beaucoup ça va dépenser de
l'argent pour rien l'argent c'est quand
même quelque chose même un front mais
c'est quand même de l'argent il ya
normes ils feront du fonds
pour moi c'est bien quoi c'est ce
splendide
qu'est ce que ton frère défend pas jarry
des copains jeu
je m'éclate on s'amuse quoi
on fait des bonds bon on va les attendre
et au restaurant de riches ont moins
bien et après je m'achète des fringues
moi j'achète n'importe quoi par exemple
une caméra plaques
qu'est ce qui est plus important de
gagner 1000 francs ou de gagner un gros
baiser ou des garmin et 1000 francs
pagé deux idées premièrement je m'achète
un vectrex c'est un jeu vidéo avec une
ou deux cassettes et deuxièmement je
m'achète des habits des disques des
cassettes puis des sous de côté pour
allociné mes trucs comme ça mais
désirent abandonner de francs gelé
je le réalise même le désir aimant lemay
de francs alors si beaucoup plus qu'il
me faudrait beaucoup beaucoup plus ou
bien alors je pas les autres désir que
j'ai sondé le désir gratuit qui demande
pas d'argent non finalement non je ne
m'en faut les garder il ya une heure je
suis là que j'attends pour passer à
l'antenne donc au départ j'avais une
idée fixe c'est d'offrir 500 francs à
mes enfants pour leur faire un cadeau et
sas enfant dé donner à une oeuvre
humanitaire mais vu que j'ai dépassé le
temps limite de stationnement ma voiture
de tête à la fourrière et je vais
prendre 500 francs pour les donner aux
flics
[Musique]